>>Francesco Nerieri: Well, thank you ever
so much for joining.
My name is Francesco.
I lead the Cloud team in Android, and today
I'm going to talking about Google Cloud Messaging.
Last summer at Google I/O 2012 we launched
this service to bring the old Cloud-to-device
messaging system also known at C2DM out of
beta.
Along the way, we made a lot of improvements.
We made it faster, more reliable, more scalable,
we removed limitations.
We opened it up to all of you.
Opened up a bunch of new APIs.
We must have done something write.
Because the adoption for the new system has
been fantastic.
But before we jump into that, I want to take
a moment to thank all of you that today use
Google Cloud Messaging in your application
because you really help the ecosystem by reducing
the impact that your application has on battery
life, network signaling, demand of data that
goes over the wire and, in general, it improves
the user experience by providing fresh and
up-to-date data for your users.
So back to the adoption.
June 27, 2012, is the day we deprecated C2DM.
From that day until now, Google Cloud Messaging
experienced an impressive 400% growth.
This growth accelerates every single month.
In April, we were already processing over
200,000 queries per second.
If you build a list of the most popular, most
uploaded applications on the Google Play store,
including those that have nothing to do with
the Cloud, that over 60% of those today use
GCM.
So I wouldn't be surprised if many of new
this room already have an application published
that Google Cloud Messaging today.
Anyone?
That is beautiful.
So for those of you that are not yet familiar
with this product, let me quickly go over
Google Cloud Messaging to tell you what system
is all about.
Bottom line, if you have an Android application,
on the server and you want to exchange data,
that's when you want to use Google Cloud Messaging.
Today, for our example, we are going to use
a surfing application.
So the surf severer just detected there's
going to be a new massive swell in the Pacific
that is going to interest the whole West Coast
of America.
We will tell our users, you have to get ready
because surf's up.
So the surf severer opens HDPS connection
to GCM, and the first thing we do is to store
the message on the Cloud, so even if the devices
are offline, as soon as it comes back online,
we can deliver the message.
Well, there are two main ways in which you
can use GCM.
First one is what we call send to sync.
Imagine there is a surf contest, Cold Water
Classic.
So there are professionals, photographers,
that are a massive number of pictures and
video uploading on the severer.
We want to tell our Android application users
to connect to upload this media.
So we send the message via GCM, goes down
to the application.
Now the application knows to connect back
to their own server so they can download the
data and consume the media.
But there's another way you can use GCM.
There's this new swell in the Pacific and
we are going to tell every single user, while
in your particular favorite spot, the wave
size is going to be six to eight foot.
We want to pack this data into the message
and route it down to the application via GCM
so now the application can consume the data
without having to connect back.
GCM also provides a bunch of APIs to allow
developers to control the flow of the message.
One of the APIs is time to live.
It allows you to set an expiration time for
your message.
Imagine the surf severer identified my personal
favorite location, now because of the tide
and swell and wind conditions, it's a perfect
time to go surfing, now for the next hour.
Too bad I'm here giving this talk so I can't
go surfing.
So if GCM detects the message expired before
the device comes back online, it simply drops
it.
Another neat parameter is the delay while
idle.
It gives a priority for the message.
It's kind of like you can say to GCM, hey,
even if the device is connected but the user
is not looking at it, don't bother sending
it down.
These two parameters are really powerful in
combination because it gives a message a chance
to expire even if the device is connected.
Then we have multiple senders or our severer
is brilliant at detecting the wave size based
on swell conditions, tide, and the geography.
Doesn't do a good job with the wind.
Luckily, there is another service that knows
all about wind conditions.
So now our application at registration time
can tell GCM, look, I want to receive a message
from both severers.
So GCM knows that both servers are allowed
to send message to one location.
And then message multi-cast.
To send a message in GCM, you have to use
an open HDPS connection.
Now, you want to reach all your users at the
same time, well, instead of becoming complicated
to open multiple HDPS connection.
So to alleviate this problem, we decided to
allow you to set after one thousand recipients
in one request for one message.
Then there is more.
There is message re-collapsing, message repay
load.
You can read and learn all about this at developer.Android.com
under the Google Cloud Messaging section.
So last summer when we launched GCM we knew
it was just the first step.
Today, I will have a series of announcements
that will bring the mobile Cloud messaging
space to the next level.
Without any further adieu, let me introduce
our brand new service Google Cloud Messaging
XMPP end point.
So I was just talking about how multi-casting
allows you to send this one message to all
your users in a better way than exporting
these connections.
If you want to send multiple different messages
customized to all your users at the same time.
Again, there is this swell, I want to tell
all our users I have at least one favorite
spot on the coast in the west.
That surf is going to be based on their abilities,
based on the condition of the tide and the
wind what they are going to do.
So we did this little experiment in which
streaming messages with HTTP interface sequentially.
The maximum speed we reached, thanks to our
low latency, which, by the way, dropped down
to 60 milliseconds down from 95 milliseconds
when we launched the service, also using improvements
like caching and whatnot.
We had the speed 1313 messages per second.
Now, we made the same test with our new XMPP
service.
We decided to limit the speed to 4,000 messages
per second.
So let's look at this.
Now, we have surf server which has a persistent
connection established with the GCM, just
like with HTTP, you can stream a message down
via this channel.
We picked XMPP because it is a never robust
and flexible protocol and also like widely
used in the multiple libraries and multiple
programming languages that will help you deal
with a low-level details of this protocol.
But the real application protocol is the same
exact JSON we use today to send messages on
HTTP.
In this slide, I will use a simple Python
XMPP library.
You can see the URL of the new service is
gcm.google.com.
What I'm doing here.
I create a client, I connect, and then last
line this bold, I authenticate.
Even this should sound familiar to you.
The authentication use the very same user
name and password that we use to authenticate
every single HTTP message today, which is
product ID.
So these are the standard that goes over the
wire.
You can see the basics for encoding of the
project ID and API key and then the success
response stanza is from GCM.
So now you have an established persistent
connection between your server and GCM which
is authenticated and the only thing that is
left do is stream down messages as fast as
you can.
But more messages we use the classic message
XMPP standard.
Nothing interesting to look here.
The only interesting part is JSON which should
sound familiar to you.
We use data, collapse key, time to live, label
idle.
The only two little differences are those
in red.
First one, two field replaces the old registration
ID field.
Yet, the value for this field is registration
ID.
The message identifier, this is an important
concept, it is unique per message, has mandatory
and has to be set by the third-party server.
The reason is really simple.
On the HTTP interface, that's a synchronous
protocol.
You send a message and we give you back a
response as to what happened to the message.
For XMPP, this is streaming.
It is completely asynchronous.
You can send down messages and we have to
tell you what happened to those by giving
you back an acknowledgment.
To make sure we are talking about the very
same message, we use this identifier.
So talking about streaming.
So now the surf server is streaming down messages
as fast as he can.
Now GCM processes this messages.
As soon as it processes a message, it has
acknowledgment or negative acknowledgment
if something went wrong.
Well, the acknowledgment is a simple message
stanza and three fields inside are the from,
which is registration ID of the device we
just sent the message to.
The message identifier, which is what I just
talked about, and the type is NACK.
For a negative acknowledgment there is a field
which tells you error and tells you an error
code that gives you a hint of what went wrong
so you can correct it and send it again.
So what I was saying how you can stream 4,000
messages per second via this interface.
But we give you more.
We give you up to 10 private connections,
persistent connections so you can actually
reach 40,000 messages per second streaming.
But not just that.
You can use also the HTTP interface and you
don't have to decide a priority which one
you want to use.
If you need multi-casting, go HTTP.
If you need streaming, go XMPP.
If you want to go insanely massive trooper,
use them both in pattern.
Just have fun with it.
The next interface with acknowledge or negative
acknowledge message, all the GCM APIs that
you know about are supported by XMPP interface
except for multi-casting.
Now, the XMPP end point allows for a nice
side effect.
GCM can reach back to your server anytime
it pleases.
This leads me to introduce our next big feature
which is Google Cloud upstream messaging.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
This feature looks like the one before except
now the application streams the message back
to the Cloud via GCM.
If you think about it, it is like if you are
providing it with a virtual persistent connection
between the surf server and every single application
installation on any Android device.
The best part, we manage this for you.
It is also reliable.
We use the same reliable technology that makes
GCM such a reliable system today to stream
messaging back out.
So your application doesn't even need to think,
is that data, there is no data?
Just give us the message, we will deliver
it absolute.
So we just surfed Ocean Beach this morning
in San Francisco, I was a pretty good and
was stoked.
I decided this is my new surf location.
I click on the app and the app sends this
message to the GCM framework.
The first thing it does is store it locally
so if there is no network, as soon as data
connectivity comes back, we can deliver to
GCM on the Cloud.
On the other hand, as soon as GCM on the Cloud
receives the message, it stores it locally
there.
If the link between the surf server and XMPP
end point is down for whatever reason, as
soon as it comes back up it is delivered.
Now one thing we are really big in GCM is
we want to make this really simple.
So the API to upstream this messages just
looks like this.
Substantiate a Google Cloud messaging object,
invoke the send method and you are done.
There are three parameters.
The two, which is the project ID that the
surf server used to authenticate with the
XMPP end point, the message identifier is
set by the application and is unique per message
and the payload.
We want to provide you with another API on
top of this which is time to live.
Within the file and forget messages for upstreaming
really important.
It just behaves like the Cloud counterpart
of this API.
So I'm cruising down the coast on the line,
doing surf safari, I tell my app, keep me
up to date for the next 30 minutes by tide
and swell.
If I am in an area with no network, 30 minutes
later, GCM framework just drops the message.
If instead there is an Android and I bring
it up to the Cloud, if the connection between
the GCM server and the surf server is down,
then 30 minutes later the Cloud is going to
drop the message.
So here is how to use the API.
This is a very same send message and in overload
of this method and you can have four parameters
and the fourth one is time to live.
The values are the same for the Cloud.
Zero seconds up to four weeks.
If you specify a time to live value of zero,
then neither GCM framework nor GCM on the
Cloud will try to store the message locally
or on the Cloud.
Now, if you send a message with time to live
equals zero but we know that there is no connection,
but we tell you right away.
Because we know, we just drop the message
right there.
So we give you an error of no connection.
Also, messages from upstream, they abide by
the same rules of messages from the Cloud.
Which means there is a maximum payload.
This payload is 4 kilobytes.
If you send us a message which is 5 kilobytes.
We return, hey, we can't, message is too big.
Also, we just can't keep collecting messages
on device indefinitely.
If there is no network, after 20 messages,
we just reject the 21st.
Hey, there are too many send messages, try
later once we flush this queue.
So how do we give you these errors?
We send the message to your broadcast receiver
that you already have to receive messages
from the Cloud.
We give you the message identifier so you
know which message you are talking about and
the error code.
Now let's assume everything went well.
My new surf spot favorite, San Francisco,
goes up to the Cloud.
We are streaming it to the surf server.
Now, what we expect is that the surf server
acknowledges this message to us just like
we did for the downstream part.
And acknowledged message just looks like the
same.
We have three fields, two is registration
ID from which we got the message from.
The message identifier and the type is ACK.
So we are storing messages on the device and
on the Cloud during the obsoleting process.
When do we get rid of those?
As I said, this is a new favorite location
that is stored, we give it to GCM.
Now there is some selective ACK process going
on on the reliable message technology that
we have, so when this process happens and
GCM tells on the framework, yes, we are down
and safely stored, then GCM framework removes
it.
The same way on the Cloud, when GCM sends
the message to the surf server, and then the
message gets acknowledged, then we know that
you received it and processed it so we just
safely remove it.
If you don't acknowledge the message, we just
keep it replaying back to you.
Now, acknowledging therefore is required.
And we pile up after 100 messages on the Cloud,
for one project for one device until we start
overriding those.
So if you fail to acknowledge messages, after
a while you might start losing them.
Also, if your server is disconnected for more
than 24 hours, we deem your server down for
good and we drop every single upstream message
until we see your server again.
So this connection is pretty good.
It allows you to send messages back up.
It's reliable and so on, but there is another
really cool part to it.
It's the fact that finally we have knowledge
of what's going on in the device.
Most likely your app is not the only one that
uses this connection, so we see messages flying
through this connection upstream.
And what we can do is all the smart things.
The simple one is, well, we can delay a little
bit and bash them so we can minimize the time
when the radio state is in high-power mode
and this improves battery life.
But not just that.
We also know what's happened for this device
on the cloud.
So you have the complete picture now.
And so we have batch messages on the client,
batch messages on the server and the first
one to start to send messages then the other
one can also piggyback on this connection
and flash it down.
So we have a way to send messages upstream
reliably.
It's low latency because our connection is
there, it's encrypted.
You have to open your HDP with SSM and so
on.
And also we provide a time to leave API.
As I was saying, we were really big in making
things simple so we don't want you to say,
let me think, this is Jelly Bean so I can
use upstream.
This is Honeycomb, maybe I can use something
else.
We want to provide everything from all GCM-enabled
devices from day zero, which is from FroYo+.
So now I'm announcing how Google Cloud Messaging
met Google Play Services.
We moved the GCM from Google Play Services
and there is no reason to freak out because
the new library is compatible with the old
library and vice versa.
All this works.
So if you have an application and you don't
want to touch it, it will work now and in
future devices as well.
But if you want to use these new features,
then you can code it from FroYo+ from every
single device out there.
And also we can always keep this library compatible
going forward because all the play services
updates that bring down from FroYo+ to whatever
the device and whatever release you're on.
Of course, if you want to use a new API then
you have to code against the GCM library on
play services.
I was saying that we want to make things simpler,
so we took the opportunity to simplify also
the registration process.
Until now you had to declare an intent receiver
on the manifest, create a broadcast receiver
for your registration, send an intend, receive
the registration and then block with an HTTPS
call to the server.
Well, we just decided to provide a new method,
which is register, you pass the project IDs,
the sender IDs, and then what you get back
is registration or an exception.
So this allowed us to remove all the code
from the manifest for registration and now
only thing you have to do is declare permissions
and the receiver for your messages.
But more.
A lot of applications today they try to register
multiple times.
Maybe they'll lose registration, maybe they
want to make sure they're still registered.
So what we're doing in this new method when
we accept registration request, we send to
GCM in the cloud, we generate it and then
we store it locally in our cache and then
we give it back to the application.
So next time the application wants to register,
then we serve it from our cache and we avoid
network hits.
But because of that we need to make sure that
our cache is consistent with our servers.
So when we deem that it's the best time to
do so, like maybe we are exchanging batches
of messages from the device to the cloud and
vice versa, then we also started synchronization
process in which we make sure that registration
matches exactly the registration on the server
for this device.
Okay.
So now we have an XMPP connection from your
server to GCM.
We stream down messages as fast as you want.
We have the application on every device, and
FroYo+ is upstream back messages tell us new
upstream location perfect, whatever.
We can start doing something cool.
You know, today we have a problem, which is
a lot of users, they're having more than one
device.
That's not the problem, but it's common to
have a phone, a tablet at home, some people
have things called phablets.
Lately you see people wearing smartphones
on their faces and they talk to them, too.
Whatever.
So my friends are out there surfing.
They want to make me jealous and say, dude,
today was classic.
And I see this message and it's fine, I'm
happy for them, but when I'm home and I swipe
my tablet on and I see the message again and
then I look up to the right and it's up here
and I go to the website and I check the webcam
because I now want to go surfing and the message
is still there.
One time makes me jealous.
Five times is a little bit too much.
So we want to provide an API to make it simple
for you to dismiss this notification after
the user interacted.
So what I'm going to announce now is the new
Google Cloud Messaging API user notifications.
Now, this API has two parts to it.
Today if the surf server wants to send a message
to me, Francesco, the user, it has a mapping
of user name or registration IDs, and then
send a message to GCM and then GCM delivers
it.
What would be really cool if the surf server
could say, hey, GCM, send this message to
Francesco and GCM figures out which devices
I have and then delivers it.
Well, because if you do this, we can do really
smart things.
So GCM receives the message for Francesco
and now he knows I have three devices.
Two of them are idle, one is active and so
we can send to the active one and keep the
message for the other ones on the cloud because
all we want to reach is me, not particular
devices.
But even better, so we mention that now I
have all my devices that are idle, but yet
GCM knows that this one was active 60 seconds
ago.
And the other two are actually 80 miles away
from this.
They're in Santa Cruz at my house.
So if I have new message coming in and I want
to ding the user, most likely I will send
the message to this one device and I still
keep the message on the cloud for the other
two.
So how do we do this?
What we need to transfer the knowledge from
the third-party server to GCM about the user
and his registration IDs.
So we provided a new API and a new end point
to do so.
It's an HTTP end point.
The URL is android.google.api.com/gcm/notifications.
Here you can see the header, classic authentication
is project ID API key.
And in the body you have a JSON protocol.
Now, the operation is create and the notification
key name is the user.
And now, we don't need to know who the user
is, so please give us a hash of whatever user
name or email address that you use to identify
them.
And then the least registration IDs.
And back we gave you a notification key.
So if the user installs the application on
a new device, then you can use the add operation
to add the registration ID to a key or vice
versa to remove the registration ID to a key.
So now that we have this knowledge, how do
we send the message to a user?
It's the same thing except in the two rather
than having a registration ID, now you have
a notification key.
And now to the cool part.
If we give the notification key to our devices,
then the device can send an upstream message
to the notification key so GCM can reach the
other ones.
And to do so we can use the very same user
notification API.
So we say, hey, send this message to Francesco
and the payload contains the notification
key.
So now all my devices have a notification
What I can do now is I receive the message
from my friends, this, oh, it was awesome
surf session, so I see it and then as the
Google Play director would say, swipe it away.
So I can see in an upstream message a notification
key saying, okay, this notification has been
read and so you can dismiss it on the other
devices, and now GCM delivers it to the other
devices.
But even more, if you specified on the notification
key, we also deliver it to the surf server
on the cloud so you can remove it from your
Web properties or whatever other channels
you might have.
How to use this API is simple.
We use the very same send absolute, and the
two, instead of being a project ID, is a notification
key.
And you can also use the time to deliver API
for this one as well.
We can also do some optimization.
As I said, I receive a message, I note the
two devices are idle, one is active, so I
send to one, keep the message on the cloud
for the other two and now I read the notification,
I dismiss it and I send an upstream dismiss
notification key message, so now all that
we need to do is get rid of the messages on
the cloud.
This saves two network hits, one to send,
one to dismiss, for both devices.
The notification key is intended to be used
to group registration IDs or devices for one
user.
So we allow maximum 10 registration IDs for
notification key.
The notification key name has to be unique,
the hash of the user name or email address.
And this API is available for both the XMPP
and the HTTP end points.
Well, four weeks ago I was talking to a colleague,
a friend of mine, Android engineer, his name
is Chris Rand, about this API, and he was
really excited.
So a couple of days later he send me a video
of a really popular application which is Google
calendar, and what he did with this API.
So this morning actually he sent me another
video which is a little bit better than that
one to show me what he did on this application.
So we have three devices.
This is a calendar event.
You swipe it on one, it goes away on the other
two.
Now we have more than one event, he swipe
one and the other two devices just get rid
of that exactly one.
And then when you swipe all the notifications
because there are all kind of notifications,
then the other two as well get rid of that.
[ Applause ]
>>Francesco Nerieri: Thank you.
I hope I got you guys excited.
I think this is these are really, really cool
features.
If you want to read more about this just point
to developer.android.com under the play services
and Google Cloud Messaging section.
If you want to get ready and start using these
APIs, please do sign up on this form.
We'll roll out the whitelisting for the next
couple of weeks.
I take all the questions for the next 30 minutes
at the Android booth office hours, and I'll
leave with you a beautiful map of the Monterey
Bay.
I hope you enjoyed this speech.
Thank you very so much for listening.
[ Applause ]